Gotta get on
the old Pilates, everyone.
Pilates for the back.
He's even doing the Pilates.
If you dunno
what Pilates is, by the way,
Pilates
is basically atheist yoga.
That's all it seems to be,
Pilates.
Doing it a while now.
All it seems to be.
It's just atheist yoga.
It's yoga without
all the fucking, you know,
ghosts, you know.
There's none of that.
None of that in Pilates.
Pilates is more like
bend over this stick.
There is no God.
That's Pilates.
The other day
I gave a homeless guy $5.
Should've been a good deed,
should've been a good deed.
But I didn't give him
$5 for him,
I gave him $5 for me.
You ever give
or do something good,
just hoping
God will notice you?
Like, I basically was trying
to kickstart a blessing.
Like, I was basically
looking at God
as I was giving this bum
some to money.
Like, look at me, Lord,
I'm a good person.
Shine your light on me.
And I'm so full of shit.
Everybody
I spoke to that day,
I slipped in
that I gave this guy $5.
No matter what
they was talking about,
say, "Hey, man,
you see LeBron?"
"No, I was too busy
giving this bum some money."
"I had no time."
And I'm bragging
about giving him $5.
Meanwhile, I had about 400
in my pocket.
So, I'm going past big money
to give him little money.
I'm like, nope, nope,
can't have that. Nope, nope.
Nope, nope, not for you.
Nope, nope.
That's for strippers later.
Nope, nope, nope.
Like, I gave him enough
for something at McDonald's,
but nothing to drink.
Like,
get yourself a number eight.
Dry.
Stay with me.
I think Harry Potter
is based on the KKK.
Let's take a journey.
So, in the KKK
they have grand wizards.
What is Harry?
A grand wizard.
In the KKK
they wear hooded cloaks.
What do they wear
at Hogwarts?
Hooded cloaks.
In the KKK,
they have something called
a night hawk and a granturk.
That's something found
in the Forbidden Forest.
Now, the whole premise
of the KKK,
premise, what?
No,
the KKK's whole deal is...
is keeping White people
and Black people separate.
The whole premise
of Harry Potter
is keeping magical people
and non-magical people
separate.
So, if we follow my logic,
not yet,
fucking checks out, okay?
Non-magical people
are Black people
and they call them muggles.
And a slur for them
is mudblood,
which is like the N-word
of the Wizarding World.
Also at Hogwarts,
they have muggle studies.
I was like, huh?
That's just
Black History month.
Arabic curse words.
They're really graphic.
They're so graphic,
I don't even use them.
Honestly, I just...
We're gonna start here
and build up.
Like "Kes Emak",
which means
fuck your mother's pussy.
Very specific.
We take that
to another level.
"Kes Emak Eli Nafadek",
which means, which...
two people. Yeah,
I know what that means.
Everybody else
is on their toes.
What does it mean?
It means
"Kes Emak Eli Nafadek",
which means fuck the pussy
you slithered out of.
Wow.
Stuff for the line.
I know, it's crazy.
That's why...
everyone
saw the baby fall out.
It's a visual curse word,
that one.
This is one
of my personal favourites.
"Yelaen Tarekhek",
which means, which means,
damn your entire history.
My great grandmother?
No, bitch.
From
the beginning of time...
to present day
and everything in between
and in the future.
Fuck your DNA.
I dunno why men are obsessed
with their dicks.
It's pretty funny.
Every man in here knows
what I'm talking about.
Every dude in here's
measured his dick before.
And I don't mean
just with a ruler.
Anything that could be
the shape of a dick.
Hair brush, shampoo bottle.
Ladies, if you ever
go in the bathroom
and you see
the remote control there,
like, why is
the remote control in here?
'Cause we gotta get scaled.
Women don't measure
their genitals.
I dunno if it's 'cause
you're smarter than us
or because you just
haven't figured out how yet.
I mean, what would you do?
Would you fill it with water
and stand over a bucket?
I got two cups of pussy.
2 cups of pussy sounds like
a Mega Nostalgia song.
Two cups of pussy...
I like Mega Nostalgia,
but...
I do not understand WAP.
Like, wet-ass pussy
all the time? For real?
You got like a condition
or some shit?
That's right,
my pussy's wet all the time.
Funerals,
birthday parties...
court.
Let's talk
about the purity rings.
For those of you
who don't know,
purity rings are worn
to demonstrate
that you're abstaining
from sex before marriage
and the Jonas brothers,
they all had them.
Like, I know this is a roast
and you will think I should
be going after them,
but I think we need
to set the record straight.
No, the rings
weren't a good idea.
Yes, as a gesture,
they're laughably
toe-curlingly lame,
but remember,
this was about
more than a gesture.
This was about faith.
This was about principle.
This was about
taking a stand
and setting an example.
Look, Joe Jonas wasn't just
sticking his fingers
in some dumb metal rings.
He was sticking his fingers
in co-stars, actresses,
and even a supermodel
or two.
Hey, whoever invented
the bagpipes,
I don't think
he's finished yet.
You ever look
at that monstrosity?
He must have thought
there was a deadline
at the patent office.
He probably just ran in
and threw that on a counter.
"Am I too late?"
"What in the world is that?"
"It's a bag
with pipes stuck in it."
"I stuck the pipes
in a bag."
"Bagpipes."
"No, I see it."
"Why?"
"What does it do?"
"It's a bag with the pipes
sticking in and out of it."
"What does it do?"
Beep.
"What does it do?" Beep.
"What does it do?"
Why?
What does it do?
How can you tell
if anybody
is ever playing them well?
You have a guy over here...
beep, beep.
He's the best!
This guy's over here...
He doesn't know
how to play that thing.
Stick your outboard motor
in the bag.
Everybody knows that.
An open window
A novel
A couple holding hands
An avocado
A poem
Written in the sand
Fresh fallen snow
on the ground
A golden retriever
in a flower crown
Is this heaven?
Or is it just
A White woman
A White woman's Instagram
White woman
A latte foam art
Tiny pumpkins
Fuzzy comfy socks
Coffee table
made out of driftwood
A bobble head
of Ruth Bader Ginsburg
A needlepoint of a fox
Some random quote
from Lord of the Rings
Incorrectly attributed
to Martin Luther King
Is this heaven?
Or am I looking at
A White Woman
A White woman's Instagram
White woman
Her favourite photo
of her mum
The caption says
I can't believe it
It's been a decade
since you've been gone
Mama I miss you
I miss sitting with you
in the front yard
Still figuring out
That I keep
living without ya
It's got a little better
but it's still hard
Mama I got a job
I live in my own apartment
Mama I got a boyfriend
and I'm crazy about him
Your little girl
didn't do too bad
Mama I love you
Give a hug and kiss to Dad
A goat cheese salad
A blacklit hammock
A simple glass of wine
Incredibly derivative
political street art
A dreamcatcher
bought from Urban Outfitters
A vintage neon sign
Three little words
A couple of dogs
And a ring on her finger
from the person she loves
Is this heaven?
Or is it just
A White woman
A White woman's Instagram
White woman